all right that's right you all your
haters
spew it the boy he's trash and you know
it and every time you bring him up I'm
gonna let the world know exactly what he
is
you say that he's a bad quarterback I
think he's good I say he's a good
quarterback not bad I say
with sports the same thing I say with
any other record if you want to play
video games like there's nothing in
principle wrong with that but if you
find yourself
taking it really seriously okay if you
play a video game and and if you like
video games but then if someone else
thinks that video games are stupid and
that makes you
like and that fills you with Rage that's
an indication that you take this way too
seriously because you don't you're not
an adult you're not you're not an
intellectual mental adult you're still a
child what so any kind of recreation
because we're a very unserious country
with unserious people any kind of
recreation can become a barrier to
maturity if if you become too invested
in